Guten morgen liebe guten morgen tippen.
Das jahr geht zu ende es weihnachtet sehr und alle wollen was gespendet bekommen.
Das auch die brauchen noch ein paar passwörter.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertvierundzwanzig und aller voraussicht nach die letzte logbuch netzpolitik sendung in diesem jahrzehnt.
Ja
Ich hoffe jetzt hat schon keine angst gehabt ne wir senden natürlich weiter aber es mal wieder eine dekade durch.
Wird irgendwie gar nicht so groß thematisiert dass wir jetzt in die goldenen zwanziger übergehen das kommt wahrscheinlich noch.
Das kommt noch ja ja wir.
Bemühen uns ja um den chaos communication kongress.
Und kann deshalb nicht,
und deshalb nicht die zeit oder scheuen den stress und dann auch noch eine livesendung dort anzutun der wir sind ja damit beschäftigt anderen diese veranstaltung als bühne zu generieren.
Schmackhaft zu machen ja und der rest ist dann auch im weihnachtskollekte wird nicht viel wird nicht viel produziert aber die machen wir noch.
Ne diese hier machen wir noch und dann sehen wir uns auf dem kongress und im sendezentrums kann man bitte auch dieses mal wieder eine bühne geben.
Es wird eine bühne geben da werden podcast stattfinden ich habe allerdings allerdings überhaupt gar keinen überblick was da genau laufen wird damit bin ich nicht befasst wir lassen uns überraschen.
Wir haben ein besonders schönes feedback bekommen,
das ein bisschen glaube nichts könnte besser zeigen was die motivation ist warum wir hier diese sendung machen.
Hallo linus und tim dank eurer berichterstattung zu der hilfsorganisation kakadus.
Die mir davor gänzlich unbekannt war ihr erinnert euch das war die.
Dreihundertsiebzehn.
Dreihundertsiebzehn wo sepp bei uns zu besuch war und von cardios berichtet hat der terror hacker und maker space hilfsorganisation die in,
nord syrien und kurdistan menschen humanitäre hilfe leistet und in berlin daran forscht und nicht nur in berlin aber in einem berliner space auch daran forscht.
Herr.
Die dafür notwendigen gerätschaften möglichst kostengünstig und open source zu entwickeln um die menschen zum und die menschen mehr möglichkeiten zu bieten sich dann nachhaltig auch selber zu versorgen,
eine ganz besondere sendung wie ich finde,
jedenfalls schreibt uns dazu patrick dadurch habe ich nun endlich ein schönes ehrenamt gefunden dass meine interessen und fähigkeiten entspricht und kakadus hat demnächst ein steuermann für die mobile müllverbrennungsanlage viele grüße patrick.
Genau dazu gab es noch ein schönes foto von dem apparat sowas freut uns natürlich besonders ich habe dann auch von carlos die hatten ja jetzt gerade noch so eine schöne supporter party letzte woche konntest du leider nicht hin.
Ja ich hab's leider nicht geschafft hinzukommen.
Es gab wohl eine menge rückmeldungen nach unserer sendung.
Ja das ist doch toll dass dafür machen wir das doch die party soll sehr geil gewesen sein es gab schoko totaler und casinos mit den schoko talern und man konnte sich mit den schoko talern an der bar irgendwie dann auch getränke kaufen.
Es gab mexikaner.
Super also das ja ich hab's leider nicht geschafft dorthin zu gehen,
ja aber genau das ist glaube ich die motivation warum wir uns das hier antun und damit kommen wir auch zu der diskussion die wir mit der letzten sendung ein bisschen motiviert haben und zwar,
spotify und die metaebene jetzt ist das natürlich so es gab relativ viel zustimmung dass wir nicht auf spotify sein müssten deshalb war auch jetzt bei aller liebe nicht verwunderlich,
weil dieses feedback kommt ja von leuten die uns woanders hören und daher wahrscheinlich kein bedarf haben uns auf spotify zu hören.
Und die anderen kennen uns gar nicht die anderen millionen.
Die anderen die anderen kennen uns nicht das ist insofern das braucht jetzt ich weise so bei aller liebe braucht man auch nicht weiter auszuwerten weil wir haben halt nur die eine hälfte gefragt ja.
Tja.
So wir haben das thema ressourcen verödung überstrapazieren von ressourcen.
Resource finde ist das motto des kongress,
wir werden da am ende auch nochmal eine kleine referenz zu haben ein kongress wird stattfinden jetzt schon sind,
viele menschen in leipzig dabei den kongress aufzubauen ganz ohne eure spenden und ohne eure itunes sternchen rennen sie durch,
ungeheizt e messehallen und bauen einen kongress für euch auf nur damit ihr dann kommen und euch beschweren könnt
das ist doch wirklich ein schönes engagement was dort geleistet wird.
Mir ist schon klar dass jetzt die leute in die kommentare kommen die kein ticket bekommen haben.
So ist das,
die der c dieses jahr mit zwei veranstaltungen camp und congress durchaus ein surfen auf der belastungsgrenze.
Weil letztendlich im prinzip als das camp abgebaut war war war die war es eigentlich schon zu spät und mit der vorbereitung des kongress anzufangen.
Wir haben deshalb,
dieses jahr uns zum ziel gesetzt in die den kongress genau so zu machen wie er,
im letzten jahr war das geht jetzt insbesondere in so diese infrastruktur fragen ja das ist ein ein großprojekt welches von.
Ehrenamtlichen menschen in ihrer freizeit und urlaubszeit oder unbezahlten arbeitszeit gerockt wird.
Und da gibt es eben eine reihe an so.
Interdependenz die erstaunliche butterfly effects haben mein lieblings beispiel ist,
irgendjemand entscheidet spontan an tag null oder hast du auch immer an welchem tag die tische anders hinzustellen,
in irgendeiner in irgendeinem bereich jetzt hatte aber das noch das network operation center schon zu diesen tischen spezifisch strom und netz gelegt,
was irgendwie unter bodenplatten entfernung und steigere einsatz passiert ja und so das quasi kleinste änderungen.
Lange absprache koordinations folgen und so weiter haben für die anderen freiwilligen helferinnen und helfer deswegen haben wir jetzt so als,
ziel uns gesetzt.
Alles was infrastruktur ist und alles was die deko ist oder so so zu tun wie im letzten jahr um eben den neu planungsaufwand zu minimieren.
Wie gut das jetzt funktioniert hat werden wir dann sehen.
Ich war ja schon vor ort kann dir sagen der begriff copy und face ist schon so eine running gag.
Ja ja das ist.
Ja ja da machen wir.
Scheint sich jetzt.
Dass das wenigstens erkennen die leute dadurch dass wenn sie etwas anders machen als im letzten jahr dass die rücksprache mit anderen halten müssen.
Es läuft aber an sich ganz gut also es ist.
Es läuft ganz gut aber wenn man die sich jetzt mal hier unsere leute aus dem lok vor allem anschaut logistik obg logistik operation center die sind.
Ich glaube irgendwann so wann war das in der ende der ersten septemberwoche müssten die in in mildenberg vom acker gerollt sein als der letzte vierzigtonner verzurrt war unter weggefahren ist.
Und die sind dann drei monate später stehen die wieder.
In leipzig und machen wieder in monat.
Ja das ist alles sehr ehrenwert aber die stimmung ist gut.
Stimmung ist gut aber dieses engagement dieser menschen ist.
Lobenswert und das führte uns eben zu dieser zu diesem motto unter anderem resource schön wo es eben ein bisschen um die nachhaltigkeit geht um das
erschöpfen von ressourcen das ja jetzt aufgrund der klimadebatte die,
menschheit sehr beschäftigt dann die ressource exotischen angriffe also eine angriffs kategorie in die zum beispiel so dinner of service angriffe fallen.
Und dieses wortspiel wie wir es ja häufig haben bei c mutti hat uns sehr gefallen ist jetzt das motto des,
kongress und bestimmt eben auch ein bisschen die themen,
resilienz und nachhaltigkeit ist ein eigener track im politik track finden wir auch relativ viel und im science track relativ viel zu den themen der nachhaltigkeit,
und der der klimaforscher und freuen uns auf den kongress.
So passwort spender.
Genau wer eure passwort spende ja ihr müsst ihr müsst jetzt ein passwort solli ihr wisst ein passwort soli leisten leid.
Es gibt einfach zu wenig passwörter.
Es gibt zu wenig passwörter.
Insbesondere im besitz der behörden.
Es soll nämlich jetzt ein neues gesetz zur bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus und der hasskriminalität geben und da soll es darum gehen,
das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz dahin zu ändern dass inhalte nicht mehr nur gelöscht werden also ihr wisst ja ist das mit den vierundzwanzig stunden löschfrist.
Sondern bestimmte inhalte soll dann auch direkt den bh gemeldet werden das justizministerium sagt dass.
Künftig hakenkreuz postings morddrohungen volksverhetzende inhalte und vieles mehr direkt nach,
direkt ans bka gemeldet werden sollen dann zum beispiel auch die ip-adresse und die portner immer direkt dazu.
Schreibt spiegel online das hat das justizministerium aber wieder gegenüber heise online nicht bestätigt das sind jetzt so die,
die sachen die noch im im netz der bereich sind jetzt gibt es aber noch eine sehr spannende ergänzung denn.
Man möge doch bitte auch die möglichkeit,
bieten im rahmen des paragraph fünfzehn telemediengesetz es auch passwörter rauszurücken dazu stehe schreiben sie in der,
erklärung zu dem gesetz also oder in den kommentar zum gesetz,
hier der hendrik wie du wild veröffentlicht hat,
netzreporterin oder netz journalisten redakteur bei der faz,
zu nummer zwei einfügung fünfzehn aufgrund der zunehmenden nutzung und gestiegenen bedeutung von telemediendiensten,
telemediendiensten sind so blogs chat dienste spiele apps und so weiter ist die erhebung von bestandsbau und
nutzungs- daten gegenüber telemediendiensteanbieter sowohl für die strafverfolgung als auch für die gefahrenabwehr von zentraler bedeutung dennoch ist das auskunftsverweigerung im telemediengesetz bisher nur rudimentär geregelt
insbesondere fallen regeln zu auskunft anhand von ip-adressen zur abfrage von passwörtern zur vertraulichkeit der ausfall und zur.
Zur vertraulichkeit der auskunft und so form des auskunftsersuchen die fehlenden verfahrens regelungen erschweren das einholen von
auskünften gegenüber telemediendiensteanbieter der der genau umfang ihrer verpflichtungen nicht hinreichend klar geregelt ist,
der neue regelt daher das auskunft zu fahren gegenüber telemediendiensteanbieter neu die regelung orientiert sich hierbei an,
paragraph hundertdreizehn absatz eins stellt zunächst klar dass die auskunft aufgrund einer verpflichtung und nur gegenüber den den absatz drei genannten stellen
erteilt werden darf die regelung wird ausdrücklich auch auf passwörter erstreckt und bietet somit die regelungen
paragraph absatz eins satz zwei der fdp ab außerdem wird die auskunft erteilung anhand von ip-adresse geregelt die das gegenstück zu
paragraph einhundert absatz zwei bildet so das ist.
Unterhaltsam das ist sehr unterhaltsam die wollen also bei diesen abfragen gibt es ja.
Da wird geringer regelmäßig unterschieden zwischen dem bestandsdaten das sind die im prinzip deinem account zugeordneten sich nicht oder nur selten ändernden festen datensätze und den verkehrsdaten das wäre jetzt also kommunikationseinheit.
Was sie sehr häufig sagen ist ja eine bestandsdaten auskunft ist ja im prinzip nur die halter feststellung im im straßenverkehr und das wird ja wohl möglich sein dass wir hier im internet ein kennzeichen haben,
dazu jetzt aber ein passwort zu zählen ist natürlich eine echt sportliche herangehensweise denn.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es verboten ist aber also ob es jetzt gesetzlich verboten ist aber es entspricht garantiert nicht den sorgfaltspflicht würde als fahrlässig gelten und garantiert auch,
geahndet werden würde ein anbieter passwörter im klartext speichern,
das wäre absolut inakzeptabel und ich weiß nicht seit wie vielen.
Also das wäre nicht nur inakzeptabel das ist auch inakzeptabel und wird jedem der es dann in den letzten jahren gemacht hat auch ordentlich um die ohren gehauen.
Also auf jeden fall ja wenn wenn irgendwo eine also es ist jetzt nicht so als würden nichts als würden keine
accounts aufgemacht und dann die die inhalte der datenbanken geliegt und wenn dabei dann passwörter raus purzeln dann ist das,
auf jeden
ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen wie das gesetzlich ist aber es ist auf jeden fall fahrlässig und gegen gegen alle regeln der kunst und im zweifelsfall dann eben auch mit strafen verbunden.
Aber teilweise auch,
praxis also es gibt ja so geschichten wie so banken die dann bei der telefon auskunft so die letzten drei ziffern oder die ersten drei ziffern von deinem passwort
telefonisch abfragen und solche geschichten wo man nur hoffen kann dass wenn sie das schon machen dass es dann überhaupt mal noch
genau diese bereiche nochmal separat gespeichert werden aber natürlich dann einfach ja also es geht einfach auch überhaupt nicht und das müsste eigentlich dahingehend verbessert werden das
so was nicht geht und nicht jetzt genau die andere richtung eingeschlagen wird sagen so ja passwörter mal her.
Völliger völliger wahnsinn vielleicht noch ganz kurz weil wir haben's zwar wahrscheinlich hier schon öfter erklärt aber weil die frage wahrscheinlich kommen wird.
Die.
Passwörter werden wenn das jetzt richtig gemacht wird bei euren anbietern wird nicht das passwort selber gespeichert sondern im prinzip eine prüf summe die über euer passwort gebildet wird und die prüft summe hat die eigenschaft dass man sie
schnell bilden kann von eurem passwort.
Sie lang genug ist und genug intro pie hat dass es quasi ausgeschlossen ist das versehentlich ein anderes passwort die gleiche summe hat,
und das aber aus der prüf summe kein rückschluss auf euer passwort,
erfolgen kann die die funktion zur erstellung der prüft summe ist quasi uni direktion du kannst,
jedem passwort innerhalb von sekunden von millisekunden die summe berechnen du kannst aber nicht aus der prüf summe
das passwort berechnen nennt sich hash und,
jetzt noch viele weitere techniken das,
zu verbessern aber was garantiert.
Die.
Inakzeptabel wäre es das passwort so im klartext in die datenbank zu schreiben und einer der gründe warum man das nicht macht und nicht darf und ich soll und was nicht alles ist das
eben menschen entgegen aller erklärung entgegen aller vernunft und entgegen allem risiko bewusstseins.
Ihr passwort an mehreren stellen verwenden das heißt also hier,
einfach nur weil man weiß dass das risiko besteht dass menschen das tun wie wäre also hier die abfrage bei einem telemediendiensten würde unter umständen eben das passwort freigeben was die gleiche person bei anderen telemediendiensten nutzt das heißt wir werden hier
auch rechtlich in einem absoluten,
risikobereich das nämlich hier zugangsdaten rausgegeben werden die unter umständen auch für andere dienste genutzt werden völlig inakzeptabel idee und man fragt sich ernsthaft in welchem.
Ja also das jahrtausend sieht man ja sie beziehen sich auf diese hunderter paragraphen und das sind ja so die,
telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Betreffenden wo ja auch schon die staatstrojaner dran gedruckt werden das ist also genau diese diese denk form an der man sagt ja moment mal wir haben ja hier nach hundert ps das recht telefone abzuhören jetzt benutzen die leute aber irgendwas was
ähnlich funktioniert und sich nicht zentral bei der deutschen post tappen lässt
ja und jetzt müssen wir es kann ja nicht sein dass die realität gegen das gesetz verstößt ja und wir wir müssen alles so machen wie es früher einmal war und das ist eine sehr sehr sehr
schlechte idee also passwörter herausgabe.
Dann muss man sich also.
Also die passwörter sind natürlich jetzt in dieser geschichte der eigentliche aufreger wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe ist aber die primäre ziel,
zielrichtung dieser novelle vor allem eine automatisierung der abfragen also das quasi die großen anbieter verpflichtet werden für diese ganze bestandsdaten auskunft auch eine entsprechende bereitzustellen dass man eben.
Prozess schneller machen kann also hier kommt dann eben auch noch dieser aspekt der automatisierung dieser abfragen nach was das bedeutet ist auch klar man will halt
mehr davon
und zuverlässiger durchführen können das mag im hinblick auf netzdg und überprüfung von rechtswidrigkeit von öffentlichen verlautbarung auch wünschenswert sein ich mache hinzufügen also ist ja.
Umstritten dieses netz ist ist ja sozusagen dass das ziel dieser maßnahme durchaus etwas was man unterschreiben kann dass man einfach,
wege findet leuten die einfach online auf andere eindreschen auch entsprechend etwas entgegensetzen zu können.
Aber wie immer scheint hier jemand mal wieder einen schritt zu weit gegangen zu sein.
Also das ist ja in der regel so dass ich finde es sehr schön dass diese trennung nochmal bringst ja das ziel es mag ja ein heeres ziel sein.
Aber nur weil du ein leeres ziel hast heißt das ja nicht dass du einfach abitur wäre beknackte mittel auswählen könntest
am ziel vorbei schießen das hatten wir bei dem ersten netzdg so das haben wir auch damals schon so gesagt dass das kein weiterbringen würde und das haben wir jetzt hätten wir jetzt wieder so und es hilft ja nichts probleme werden nicht
mit der gleichen denkweise gelöst wie mit der sie geschaffen wurden und,
geht hier,
nur so weiter ein bisschen traurig habe gestern im rahmen der vorgespräche zum chaos communication kongress mit einem journalisten gesprochen der mir so fragte so ja sag mal wie wie wie findet ihr das eigentlich das.
Also würdet ihr euch wünschen dass öfter mal jemand auf euch hört.
Ja wer würde sich das denn nicht wünschen.
Aber es ist natürlich sehr also ich würde mir das,
nicht nur in unserem bereich wünsche ich mir das mal an vielen anderen bereichen wünschen wir haben gerade hier diese ganzen.
Jetzt sind ja inzwischen alle for future ne aber so ich sag mal die relevanten bewegungen sind fridays for future und scientist for future die anderen sind auch nett,
aber es ist natürlich schon irre wenn die politik sich so dermaßen die scheuklappen aufsetzt,
gegenüber dem was eben expertinnen und experten
sagen und das es scheint so irgendwie ein fortlaufendes es kann doch nicht sein politikstil zu sein ein fortlaufender es kann doch nicht sein politikstil und das kann doch echt nicht sein.
Das kann auch nicht sein ja vor allem sind immer wieder dieselben antworten die vorgeschlagen werden nach dem motto wenn man nur oft genug immer wieder dasselbe sagen,
wird es dann irgendwann schon mal stattfinden egal wie oft schon dargelegt wurde wie schädlich das ist oder wie sinnlos das ist auch wahlcomputer fallen ja in diese diskussion mit rein.
Ja das erinnert an die von mir so geschätzten stuhlkreis diskussionen ja in denen auch ein thema einfach nach belieben,
wenn einem langweilig ist einfach nochmal neu diskutiert werden kann weil weil,
vielleicht haben wir auch eine beschlussfassung dazu aber ich wollte noch mal ich wollte auch nochmal sagen dass x y ja,
und das finde auch dass sie mir jetzt zuhören müsst so und das sollte man auch einfach nochmal ergebnisoffen diskutieren.
Frei nach dem motto ist zwar schon alles gesagt aber doch nicht von jedem.
Ja so und selbst wenn es auch von jedem gesagt ist dann wollen die anderen das aber auch nochmal sagen ja also so kommst du halt nicht voran dafür haben wir dafür haben wir eigentlich diese strukturen die irgendwann auch mal realitäten schaffen.
Das dürfen die ja dann auch und dann wäre es halt auch ganz nett wenn.
Ja wenn sich das dann weiter wenn man dann auch irgendwann mal auf den erkenntnissen der vergangenheit stehen und sich weiterentwickeln könnte.
Ach ja das sind so here wünsche zum jahresende.
Wer wer auch auf den erkenntnissen der vergangenheit steht und sich weiterentwickeln möchte sind ja universitäten.
Damit an der zukunft gearbeitet.
Da wird eine zukunft gearbeitet.
Außer wenn gerade nicht dran gearbeitet.
Gießen arbeitet auch gerade an ihre zukunft.
Die zukunft der uli gießen ist ungewiss.
Das ist ja,
tragischer fall.
Die uni gießen hat alle computersysteme ausgeschaltet und alle computersysteme bedeutet in dem fall irgendwie ich glaube achtunddreißigtausend computer die ausgeschaltet haben.
Und zwar weil sie einen schadsoftware befall haben jetzt haben sie im prinzip nicht öffentlich,
bekannt gegeben welche art von schadsoftware das ist weshalb ich auch bisher in der presse die presse anfragen der dazu im prinzip nicht beantwortet habe und gesagt habe hier
ich nehme dazu keine stellung solange sie mir nicht sagen können was da überhaupt vorgefallen ist aber heise online.
Hat dazu geschrieben dass es das emoji sich sehr viel geändert hätte in letzter zeit sehr viel wandel unterzogen hätte,
haben damit jetzt im prinzip wahrscheinlich versehentlich oder vielleicht sollte es wollte es auch gar keine geheim halten jedenfalls,
entnimmt man jetzt dort dass die maschinen mit motec befallen sein könnten,
und dieser schritt die systeme nicht anschalten zu dürfen erinnert auch daran also ich hatte ja,
in der folge vor einigen wochen das erklärt wie das funktioniert die.
Die tatsächliche der befall mit dem verschlüsselungstrojaner erfolg,
über eine afd-gruppen richtlinie also die computer.
Active directory,
also die computer horchen alle sind sind quasi in ein active directory eingebunden und dann gibt's eine gruppen policy die dann eben sagt so passt auf ihr führt übrigens jetzt diesen befehl aus ne und das ist natürlich für viele,
für viele anwendungen in der it-sa,
eine sehr gute funktionalität wenn es im unternehmen bist und sagst so wir müssen wir alle jetzt hier ab dates machen oder sowas,
wir müssen bestimmte zertifikate neu installiert oder sonst was kannst du als administrator eben über eine,
flotte von rechnern walten ohne die einzeln.
Irgendwie steuern zu müssen die einzelnen bedienen zu müssen und das könnte jetzt sein ich sage das sehr spezifisch mit einem könnte sein dass hier eben 'ne adel richtlinie irgendwo an diese rechner gegangen ist und die sich jetzt eben dafür sorgen machen
wenn diese rechner eingeschaltet sind dass eine schadsoftware aktiviert wird,
aktiv bleibt weitermacht oder sonstiges und was die jetzt gerade mit diesen achtunddreißigtausend rechnern tun ist sie haben einen vielen scanner livestrem.
Heise online schreibt das wäre ihres also desinfektor nennen sie das einmal im jahr geachtete linux distribution status von dem stick,
die sucht dann halt auf den vorhandenen laufwerken nach schadsoftware und entfernt die.
Und irgendwie es wird jetzt berichtet die gingen also dort in gießen von rechner zu rechner starten die von diesem stick scannen die platten
und kleben dann irgendwie ein aufkleberchen drauf dass er den ersten scannen überschritten hat dann bleiben wir überall schilder computer bitte nicht anmachen bitte nicht anmachen und,
ja also es ist ein desaster ne ganz klar absolute katastrophe leider gibt's eben noch keine gesicherten technischen informationen dazu weshalb ich das jetzt alles so unter vorsicht sage aber es klingt eben.
Danach wenn wenn du so viele rechner befallen oder potenziell befallen hast,
wenn du dir darüber gedanken machst und nicht davon ausgehst dass der befall auf irgendein netzwerk segment oder auf irgendetwas beschränkt wäre dann hast du's im zweifelsfall mit einem,
active directory walk for zu tun wo du also einmal durch geordnet wurdest bis aufs bis auf die,
bis auf die ebene und dann hast du so eine situation in der du dir gedanken machen muss über eben eine flotte von,
rechnern eigentlich hast du nicht achtunddreißigtausend rechner in einem active directory insofern werden die wahrscheinlich eine form von.
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen noch viele andere rechner haben aber das ist auf jeden fall eine,
eine katastrophe die da stattgefunden hat es gibt ein ganz bericht von zeit online darüber,
wo irgendwie davon berichtet wird dass die studentinnen und studenten da jetzt irgendwie rumrennen da gibt's ein schönes foto von der schlange in der sie stehen und zwar nicht indem er doch war in dem artikel die stehen jetzt alle schlange weil diese,
vielen tausend accounts die die haben.
Die brauchen jetzt auch alle neue passwörter ja ein weiteres indiz dafür dass wir es hier mit einem,
walk for zu tun haben dass eben alle nutzer passwörter als kompromittiert angenommen werden können,
und jetzt diese ganzen,
studentinnen und studenten auch tatsächlich neue neue passwörter gesetzt bekommen müssen und ja da musst du dann eben schlange stehen wenn du dir nicht mehr vertrauen kannst dann musst du das so machen.
Ein desaster.
Über das ich mich persönlich ärgere dass es relativ wenig informationen zum technischen gibt andererseits werden die gerade auch anderes zu tun haben als die öffentlichkeit darüber zu informieren,
katastrophe kann man hoffen dass sie das in den griff kriegen.
Die sind da glaube ich auch nicht besonders optimistisch also so die werden halt irgendwie die sache wieder in den griff kriegen aber können glaube ich schon ihren schaden gerade noch nicht so absehen und.
Alles windows maschinen oder was.
Es gibt da wirklich so gut wie keine,
gesicherten informationen wo ich jetzt sagen würde ich gebe ich kann jetzt mal technisch was zu sagen deswegen habe ich das auch nicht gemacht aber so bibliothek so rechner mit der hand geschriebenen hinweisen thc bitte nicht einschalten das.
Zeigt schon von panik.
Zeugt von von problemen ja,
an den türen der seminarräume und büros hängt mit privaten oder hast dich neu eingerichteten web d e mail adressen an den eingang der hörsäle sind infos zu ausgefallenen seminaren oder raumforderung auf zetteln angebracht ja.
Ja früher sind ja ganz viele städte,
abgebrannt bis man dann irgendwann mal.
Ganz stringente brandschutzmaßnahmen etabliert hat das hat eine menge gebracht und dann macht man auch regelmäßig so brandschutzübung.
Jeder schule müssen die kids irgendwie zweimal im jahr mal raus rennen wenn die sirenen heulen auch wenn eigentlich gar nichts los ist das hilft schon.
Na also es es hilft auf jeden fall irgendwie notfall und wieder anlauf konzepte zu haben das sieht natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen hilflos aus ne ich erinnere mich auch bei an diese schönen.
Kreide geschriebenen teufelchen am frankfurter hauptbahnhof da kam dann also längst vergessene,
berufsbilder schilder maler das war früher konnte damit versuchen deine familie zu ernähren heute sind das auf einmal gefragte experten,
die aus dem ruhestand geholt werden wenn wenn eben bei der bahn mal der durch rasiert ist ich hoffe mein universitäten genießen meine anerkennung und sympathie.
Und ich wünsche denen da viel glück und erfolg im umgang,
mit diesem problem und freue mich natürlich dann irgendwann mal über einen sehr detaillierten sehr detaillierte beschreibung dessen was da passiert ist.
Ja gut dass wir das bier haben was uns ja für größeren gefahren beschützen soll tut's das eigentlich.
Hätte ich gedacht ne will man eigentlich meinen das bs für für bürger ja soll ja
dafür sorgen dass wir bessere sicherheit in der informationstechnik haben und hat in diesem rahmen zweitausendzehn also von neun jahren eine umfangreiche analyse der verschlüsselung software
krypto in aufregt in auftrag gegeben crypt kennt wahrscheinlich viele von euch noch.
Die haben irgendwann es war in von nicht öffentlich bekannten personen gepflegte software projekt für verschlüsselte container aber auch für voll verschlüsselte platten,
und die haben vor ein paar jahren plötzlich den betrieb eingestellt und haben gesagt hier benutzt bitte lieber microsoft bitte locker.
Das war alle saßen da so what alles was wir unser ganzes vertrauen hängen trug krypto und wer was machen wir denn jetzt seitdem wurde das projekt gefolgt und wird unter vera crypt weitergeführt
alles randbedingungen auf jeden fall ein relativ wichtiges und weit verbreitetes verschlüsselungstrojaner.
Das ist doch schön wenn sich das immer so einer software annimmt und das mal ausführlich analysiert.
Total genau finde ich super es sind so eine der sachen wo man wo man sich denkt es war doch nicht alles schlecht in im b ja.
Aber stellt sich raus.
Ja die haben die haben die haben das ding auditiert haben da drin fein dings gehabt keine enorm kritischen aber fundings und die ergebnisse.
Also timings damit meinst du so potenzielle sicherheits- unklarheiten da müsste man mal reinschauen da wird mit speicher komisch umgegangen etcetera sowas mal zu.
Genau also du du prüfst ja ob's da irgendwie zum beispiel einen buffer flow über bei gibt oder sowas ne also quasi eine,
wo speicher falsch zugeordnet wird du nimmst irgendwie zu wenig,
speicher du reservierst zu wenig speicher und wenn du dann da rein schreibst schreibst du quasi über den rand des speichers den weg was dein programm was dich eben was einem angreifer unter umständen ermöglicht an eine andere stelle im speicher zu schreiben die dann das programm in irgendeiner form aus dem,
tritt bringt es gibt ein paar oft bei fehler es gibt seitenkante also das,
rechnet das programm schneller oder langsamer je nachdem ob du näher oder an deinem ziel ist oder weiter entfernt oder strahlen die prozessoren irgendwelche,
funk signale ab,
die rückschlüsse auf den auf die operation des programms erlauben oder sonstiges ja das sind alles so seiten kanäle wurde alles.
Wurde alles irgendwie einmal durch geprüft und da gibt's einen relativ langen bericht und der hanno bock hat den angefordert,
hat gesagt hier ich ihr habt doch in zweitausendzehn mal so eine outlet gemacht ich hätte den gerne mal und dann haben sie mir wie nur teile davon geschickt dann muss da noch sagen ja ich will aber auch noch den teil eins und teil sechs und detail sieben und,
der eigentliche kracher ist dass diese schwachstellen die dort gefunden wurden.
Nicht an truck gemeldet wurden,
die schwachstellen wenn gleichzeitig kritisch sind,
finden sich tatsächlich jetzt teilweise auch noch in vera crypt.
Das heißt das ist dann schon ein bisschen krass wenn das bsi hier das wissen über schwachstellen aus ungeklärten gründen irgendwie im.
In der tasche hält finde ich komisch also dafür dass das 'ne.
Also im prinzip wir sagen ja public money public code skripte war,
also quasi open es ist open source aber nicht ganz je nach der strengsten,
strengsten regeln der der des genug oft quell offen und
genauso würde ich natürlich beim bsc sagen public money public ording ja und wenn die software auditiert die sicherheitskritische ist und von vielen städten gemeinden und bürgerinnen und organisationen und behörden eingesetzt werden.
Dann gehört das öffentlich beziehungsweise zumindest den software produzierenden gemeldet also völlig völlig komisch wie so etwas nicht,
warum die das denn überhaupt gemacht haben wenn sie das ergebnis am ende nicht einer verbesserung des produktes haben zu fließen lassen.
Völlig unklar.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Stärkt auf jeden fall nicht unser vertrauen in das bsi und ist in meinen augen eine,
ein verstoß gegen den gegen die aufgaben des bsc.
Hat mir nur in letzter zeit öfter dass es immer so ein bisschen eingezwängt ist zwischen einerseits dieser öffentlich proklamierte wir sind ja gut für die öffentlichkeit und wir schützen die wirtschaft rolle auf der anderen seite dann eben,
immer wieder diese zwänge von sicherheitsbehörden et cetera nein ihr müsst alles ganz geheim halten weil das was ihr daraus findet das könnte ja auch für einen potenziellen trojaner verwendet werden oder andere angriffe,
weil wir müssen ja jetzt im,
digitalen online silber war auch zurückschlagen können hack back etcetera und hier zeigt sich das wieder mal sehr schön und wir wissen es natürlich jetzt nicht ob das jetzt der grund war aber das ist definitiv so etwas was genau so ein verhalten,
bewirken kann weil einfach irgendjemand sagt wieso ihr habt ja schon mal was gefunden zählt das man nicht gleich weiter hier.
Und dann landest du eben genau an dieser stelle.
Fragwürdig ist ja auch das verhalten einiger anderer unternehmen in dem fall der internet society da ist ja so eine ganz alte ehrwürdige gruppe und.
Wo kommen die eigentlich genau her also was ist der was ist der hintergrund der eishockey.
Ich glaube monika herrmann hat das letztens in der heiße show erklärt nochmal aber ich ich hatte gehofft dass du das noch mal genauer.
Ich habe da nicht so viel einblick in diese ganzen strukturen weil sich das aus meiner perspektive auch,
viel zu oft geändert hat und das alles so dinge sind die in.
Sich in den usa zu einem zeitpunkt abgespielt haben als man noch nicht so richtig den,
den direkten internet zugang zu all diesen ganzen vorgängen hatte.
Aber generell geht's beim internet society halt darum dass sie für das internet eben gutes tun sollen dass sie diese fc veröffentlicht haben
und unter anderem sind sie halt auch für die dot org domain zuständig,
diamond aufgelegt wurden umso n los und ähnlichen gruppen das leben einfacher zu machen beziehungsweise als ich als solche im internet per domain,
erkennbar machen zu können das war dann eben so das bisher auch die preise die für dot org domains genommen wurden relativ.
Moderat waren im vergleich zu dem was wir so andere domains genommen wird.
Also es gab ja dann dot com das ist geschirr für commercial oder company.
Ja genau steht für company oder für commercial also eigentlich commercial.
Und dann dot org im organisation netzpolitik punkt org also natürlich kann im prinzip kann sich jede person eine domain klicken
aber die idee war dass eben den,
den non-profit irgendwie zu,
anzuziehen jetzt ist ja tatsächlich in den letzten jahren ohnehin ein starker eine starke inflation an top-level domains die stattgefunden hat ne es gab erstmal,
wahrscheinlich für jeden staaten für jeden start eine.
Damit ging's eigentlich los also die ersten domains dies gab man halt dot com dot org.
Edo.
Dort dort net und dort mill für military.
Vielleicht auch noch.
Und und kauf richtig genau government.
Military education organisation commercial und.
Genau.
Annette küche für die netten.
Das kommt halt aus der zeit als das sozusagen auch alles noch im wesentlichen planet war und das war halt ein amerikanisches netzwerk was eben
den zweck hatte das ganze akademische feld universitäre ebene forschungsgebiete militär et cetera staat
alles miteinander zu vernetzen das ist ihnen ja eigentlich auch wunderbar gelungen so und dann wurde es halt irgendwie immer
erfolgreicher und aus dem wurde das internet und irgendwann hat man dann festgestellt so jetzt kommt auch noch der rest der welt dazu dann machen wir jetzt mal für jedes land einfach mal eine top-level domaine können die da drunter das selber machen teilweise wurden dann eben diese
ideen repliziert wie man das zum beispiel in domains sehen kann so mit zwei buchstaben und
das ist so in deutschland hat das nie so stattgefunden de war einfach de und jeder hat sich da einfach was rein geklatscht,
ja und jetzt dieser move zu den ganzen anderen domains na ja gott warum nicht also ich warte ja nur darauf dass irgendwann auch nochmal jemand dort box verkaufen möchte.
Dann kann hier irgendwie mit seiner fritzbox aber einpacken.
Ich ich hätte gerne die top top level domain dort local das wäre das wäre die die ich gerne hätte.
Ja die christ aber nicht weil die ist reserviert.
Ja schade es hat sicher ich glaube das war so ein langsamer weg ne es gab ja dann gibt es ja auch zum beispiel die top-level domain von value,
punkt tv die sich natürlich dann irgendwie.
Interessant zu interessanten wortspielen nutzen lässt oder fm oder für italien wo dann irgendwie viel viele it-unternehmen sich darunter gebündelt haben und jetzt inzwischen kannst ja irgendwie was war das für hundertfünfundzwanzigtausend us-dollar kanzlerin beantragen
und wenn du die dann bekommst dann kannst du dir eben auch verkauft also dann kannst du eben subdomain dieser top-level domain verkaufen und dieses recht hat eben
die internet society.
Eine neunzehnhundertzweiundneunzig gegründeten und profit die irgendwie sich mit den standards des internets auseinandersetzt und die offene entwicklung,
die evolution des internets vorantreiben möchte die hat eben als ihr tafel silver,
eigen ist sie die eigentümerin der toplevel domain dot org und die.
Haben jetzt gerade die toplevel domain dot org die rechte an dieser domain an eine,
privatunternehmen mit den namen capital auch ein sehr schöner name ethos kapital kapital ist ja immer für sein etwas,
und nicht besser machen können und die das ist jetzt irgendwie,
naja ich meine grundsätzlich ist das ein geschäft,
so eine top-level domain zu verwalten zu verkaufen und und aufrecht zu erhalten muss man ja auch dann entsprechenden server und sowas für bereithalten und so.
Das war ein milliardengeschäft wenn ich das richtig verstehe und die zivilgesellschaft ist jetzt in heller aufruhr dass ihnen jetzt die preise angezogen werden.
Ja
Was eigentlich dann auch schon so ein bisschen ende der nachricht ist wir sehen einfach nur es ist einfach alles verkäuflich und nichts ist heilig und es war jetzt auch kein move der jetzt der internet zur zeit hier als besonders gelungen angekrallt wird.
Ne das ist auf jeden fall nicht besonders gelungen aber es gibt dann auch überlegungen tja.
Bis es es gibt zehn komma fünf millionen org domains,
die üblicherweise irgendwie von denen holz helfe neun komma neun drei us-dollar verkauft werden also hotel heißt,
ihr kauft die manja bei irgendjemand anders bei ihm registriert aber der kauft die für neun dollar dreiundneunzig ein das heißt die haben damit neun und neunzig komma drei millionen,
us-dollar einkünfte im jahr und haben's jetzt halt irgendwie verscheuert und die erwägung ist.
Wahrscheinlich dass sie sich überlegen naja wenn es jetzt eh top top level domains ohne ende gibt dann wird halt der wert einer org domain auch
sinken und deswegen ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht das ding jetzt zu verkaufen und die profis profite von ein paar jahren einzustreichen und das risiko dass nicht mehr so eine cashcow ist halt,
zu verkaufen andererseits.
Kannst du eigentlich davon ausgehen wenn jemand unter deiner domain auch was betreibt dann werden die jetzt nicht so netzpolitik org wird jetzt nicht sagen.
So wir sind jetzt
netzpolitik punkt de oder so weil die werden halt ihr leben lang daran weiter bezahlen so wie wir im zweifelsfall ein leben lang für logbuch netzpolitik de bezahlen möchten insofern soweit verkaufst du eigentlich nicht erst recht nicht ein
an ethos kapital ja
also da gibt's auf jeden fall gerade ein lautes geschrei und sehr viel unglücklichkeit dass jetzt ausgerechnet diese non-profit hier diesen handel.
Ich denke,
ich denke ohnehin dass dieser ganze domain bereich irgendwann auch nochmal wirklich einer global gültigen regulierung unterzogen werden müssen weil es ist einfach im prinzip domain verkauf.
Ist purer kapitalismus ohne bremse
weil nichts anderes zählt als hier angebot und nachfrage und die eigentliche dienstleistung dahinter steht überhaupt nicht mehr im verhältnis eben wie du schon richtig sagt es weil du ja nicht mal eben auf eine andere domain,
ausweichen kannst ist ja nicht so dass es einfach,
aussuchen kannst oder sagen kannst ich ziehe jetzt mit meiner domain wie jetzt mit einer mobilfunknummer zu nem anderen domain provider dessen ganze dienstleistungen nichts anderes ist als ein
datenbank eintrag vorzuhalten und den alle zwei jahre mal dazu eine mail zu schreiben ich meine mehr muss da nicht groß getan werden.
Nur damit da keine verwirrung es steht du kannst schon zu einem anderen registriert umziehen,
du kannst sagen was weiß ich habe meine domains bei und ich möchte aber jetzt zu horst europe oder irgendwie sowas das geht aber die zahlen alle immer den gleichen betrag an diese,
an den der der die arbeit nicht macht.
In einem bestimmten rahmen kannst du die preise senken aber neben nicht beliebig so und so sachen wie dort fm oder so die ich ja teilweise auch habe einfach ab so teuer und es ist halt einfach nur weil sie groß nachgefragt sind.
Ich will nicht wissen wie wie viel des des bruttosozialprodukts von valu die punkt tv domain ist so ne die machen sich da eine schöne schönes leben.
Ja und mikronisiert hat sicherlich auch nicht sehr viele andere einnahmequellen ja.
Was ist denn.
Was ich alles an an an mikronisiert überweise pro jahr das glaubst du gar nicht also ich bin da wenn ich dahin komme dann kriege ich gleich eine krone aufgesetzt.
Nee nee das ist ein anderer noch mehr da sagte kommst du zu den anderen in die herde.
Für den preis möchte ich aber doch eine krone aufgesetzt werden und im basti irgendwie auf dem thron durch die gegend getragen werden.
Wir haben eine gute nachricht tim du bist den knopf schnell wir haben gute nachricht.
Wir haben eine gute nachricht oh gott das.
Sorry hab ich auch jetzt kommt völlig überraschend.
Na dann mal los.
Der verfassungsgerichtshof österreich hat über die beschwerde von spö und neos entschieden,
die sich gegen das zwanzigachtzehn verabschiedete sicherheitspaket in österreich,
gerichtet hat und der gibt es einige bestimmungen die der verfassungsgerichtshof österreich jetzt aufgehoben hat und zwar.
Die verdeckte erfassung und speicherung von daten zur identifizierung von fahrzeugen und fahrzeuglenker mittels bild verarbeiten der technische einrichtungen um das mal kurz von österreichisch auf straßen deutsch zu übersetzen,
kennzeichen scanner.
Die verarbeitung von daten aus section control anlagen durch die sicherheitsbehörden section controller anlage scheiße.
Action kontroll.
Ja sagt mir auch nichts ich gucke.
Sagt mir auch nichts achso achso bereichs überwachung sozusagen also einfahrt in bestimmte bereiche straßen bereiche.
So wo man irgendwie sagt okay wenn du das jetzt schneller durchfahren hast oder so okay das okay also im prinzip das gleiche.
Die verdeckte überwachung verschlüsselter nachrichten durch installation eines programms auf einem computersystem also staatstrojaner sowie
die ermächtigung zum zweck der installation dieses überwachungs- programms in räumlichkeiten einzudringen behältnisse zu dich suchen und spezifische sicherheitsvorkehrungen zu überwinden also kennzeichenerfassung und,
staatstrojaner,
in österreich verfassungswidrig mit beschluss vom elften zwölften thomas hat die hier über die sicherheitspaket mehrmals berichtet jetzt ist es,
am österreichischen karlsruhe gescheitert und das ist doch,
schön das ist eine gute nachricht da freuen wir uns das haben wir schon immer gesagt dass dass das nicht in ordnung ist,
anlasslose überwachung und automatisierte erfassung des öffentlichen raumes durch kennzeichen scanner und,
über staatstrojaner haben wir ja auch ausreichend oft gesprochen insofern danken wir da.
Die nächste die nächste das nächste thema ist echt nicht witzig man.
Es ist echt nicht witzig man.
Ronny ronny war bei uns schon mal zu gast vor vielen jahren,
da haben sie ihn abgemahnt weil er irgendein foto von irgendeinem schlangen kuchen auf seinem blog hatte oder sowas ne,
das war irgendwie diese abmahnung bilder abmahnen gang die ihn da irgendwie versucht hat zu zu erpressen und.
Jetzt hat er irgendwie zwanzig,
oder so da war das zwanzig sechzehn sechzehn hatte ein video geblockt von einem.
Fernsehkoch in einer morgensendung der sagen wir mal eine kleine menge mehl oder backpulver,
mit hilfe einer kreditkarte vorbereitet für den kochvorgang und da so kleine länge längst gezogene streifchen auf vorbereitet.
Und es war auch noch unbezahlt das mehl also er hat auch noch fünfhundert euro schein.
Genau das war noch nicht bezahlt.
Gerollt bereit gelegt.
Da lag noch ein raum zusammengerollte fünfhundert.
Den er da eben neben diesem mehl oder backpulver hatte und ronny bei kraftfutter mischwerk verblockt e das mit dem kommentar,
so etwas wie in deutschland weiß man seit einem nicht genannten koch den er jetzt nicht nennen darf das koks genauso zu guten küche gehört wie salz und pfeffer,
das fand der genannte koch echt nicht witzig man und hat sich dann offenbar jetzt drei jahre später.
Mit einer abmahnung wegen verletzung seiner persönlichkeitsrechte an ronny gemeldet.
Und wollte irgendwie tausende haben weil ja eben der gegenstand wert der gute name,
wäre irgendwie fünfzehntausend euro der da in den dreck gezogen wurde von ronny und deswegen abmahnung fertig und jetzt hat der ronny die etwas unelegante reaktion gemacht und hat gesagt.
Ich
lass mal einen anwalt drüber gucken und macht das nach meinem urlaub das ist natürlich bei einer abmahnung schlecht es wäre klüger gewesen das offline zu nehmen
und dann sein anwalt drüber schauen zu lassen denn in der zeit die im urlaub war er wirkte dann eben,
diese kanzlei höcker die den nicht genannten koch vertritt.
Eine einstweilige verfügung und dann wird das alles noch viel teurer.
Kurz gesagt der koch ist nicht der koks oder aus der italienischen frühstück sendung sondern der koch ist ein deutscher koch der hier ein witz über seinen namen nicht akzeptieren wollte.
Und deswegen sagte das finde ich echt nicht witzig mann.
Der besagte koch verfügt glaube ich über drei irgendwie ein restaurant mit drei michelle stern.
Ich glaube wenn du dich bis zu drei sternen kochst dann hast du auch echt kaum noch humor weil das ist hartes geschäft.
Und das dann auch nicht mehr witzig man.
Ne das ist echt nicht mehr witzig man ja ronny hat hat die kohle nicht ist auch nicht witzig man.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal er bittet eben um unterstützung sich dagegen rechtlich zu wehren und sagt natürlich ja einerseits hat er.
Hat er wahrscheinlich ganz gute aussichten das so ein solcher scherz,
nicht die persönlichkeitsrechte eines ungenannten kochs verletzt aber er hat natürlich das risiko.
Wenn er sich jetzt gegen diese einstweilige verfügung zur wehr setzen und so dann dann trägst du eben das risiko der prozesskosten also abmahnung ist im prinzip hier macht das,
und bezahlt dass wir dir diesen brief schicken mussten ein zweige verfügung ist wir haben eine gerichtliche entscheidung herbeigeführt bei der du noch nicht einmal angehört wirst,
und wenn du aber jetzt dann diese einstweilige verfügung anfechten dann,
liegt das dann liegt das prozesskostenrisiko eben,
bei wem auch immer wer von beiden dann gewinnt oder verliert,
also das ist so ein bisschen wie könnte man das sagen ein zweitige verfügung ist so ein.
Ist ein risiko spielen.
Ist ein risikospiel sowohl für diejenigen die sie anstrengen.
Aber auch für diejenigen die sich dann dagegen wehren möchten du landest eben vor gericht und wer gewinnt oder verliert,
hat unter umständen das gesamte prozesskostenrisiko kann natürlich auch sein dass die gerichtskosten siebzig oder geteilt werden ja,
ich denke man muss hier seine solidarität walten lassen und helfen,
dem ronny sich hier zu wehren weil ja ist eben echt nicht witzig man.
Und dann haben wir noch ein ein fortwährendes feedback in unseren sendungen des sogar jetzt auch bei jack angekommen ist jack dorsey dem ceo von twitter und da geht es um die dezentralisierung sozialer netzwerke
tja.
Das kam überraschend.
Dass der dorsi das jetzt auch gut findet ich weiß nicht ob dir das wirklich gut findet oder ob du da einfach nur mal auf was twittern wollte.
Weiß ich auch nicht auf jeden fall hatte angekündigt dass ihr eine taskforce aufsetzen also ein team engagiert,
dass ich tatsächlich mit einem offenen standard für das internet beschäftigen soll in,
dessen ergebnis
etwas entstehen soll was an in irgendeiner form dezentralisierte föderalismus kommunikationsnetzwerke aufziehen könnte in dem auch twitter sozusagen sich einblenden,
erreichen vernetzen ließe details hatte da ehrlich gesagt nicht sehr viele zugegeben aber ich bin wirklich gespannt womit sie da aufkommen letztlich,
wirkt das so ein bisschen wieder versucht sich so ein bisschen auch aus dieser,
mäßigen verantwortung die sie durch ihre zentrale rolle angenommen haben auch ein wenig herauszuziehen.
Das ist jetzt so meine freie interpretation der geschichte wird man absehe abwarten müssen was dabei rauskommt.
Erläutert das noch so ein bisschen sagt.
Dass sie dass sie bei twitter schon früh darüber nachgedacht haben ein dezentralisierte internet standard zu werden der ähnlich wie fdp das e-mail protokoll funktionieren sollte es gäbe aber zu der zeit als die twitter haben
gebaut haben und wachsen lassen,
anderen fahrt nehmen müssen und twitter zentralisieren müssen.
Über die jahre hätte sich aber viel geändert und deswegen gab es jetzt andere herausforderungen für zentralisierte lösungen,
die wiederum dezentrale lösungen interessant machen global policy ja statt.
Gesetze des landes zu akzeptieren und ähnliches ja sodass jack dorsey sie zu der entscheidung kommt,
zu dem schluss kommt dezentralisierung sei der neue shit und das finde ich insofern spannend weil eigentlich wir zumindest was wir beobachten,
überall eine tendenz zur zentralisierung sodass ich fest davon ausgehe im prinzip zentralisierung als ein,
naturgesetz des internets im kapitalismus zu sehen weil die zentralisiertes lösungen,
eine ganze reihe an vorteilen haben gegenüber dezentralisierte ja sie können
änderungen leichter erzwingen sie können das ökosystem sich weiterentwickeln lassen und interessanterweise genau dieses beispiel fdp was jack dorsey hinnimmt,
führt moxi maximalen spike in seiner argumentation für zentralisierte systeme auch auf und sagt pass mal auf
das hat sich ja auch nicht weiterentwickelt seit fünfundzwanzig jahren sitzen wir mit der scheiße wir haben's nie geschafft,
das ding mal sinnvoll zu verschlüsseln wir haben wir müssen immer noch diese backwaren kompatibilität zu irgendwelchen
ja antiken system halten und wir können das nicht mehr weiterentwickeln das ist quasi aus der evolution ausgenommen.
Dadurch dass es dezentralisierte wurde und das argument von,
moxi finde ich auch sehr sag mal inhaltlich überzeugend wenn gleich ist meine religiösen gefühle verletzt.
Deswegen.
Deswegen nicht nur deswegen haben wir moxi uns auch beim sechsunddreißig drei als speaker.
Hm
Ich hoffe dass das dass das alles stattfinden wird und da werden wir diese diskussion über zentralisierung und dezentralisierung dann nochmal auch auf dem kongress haben.
Stelle auch fest dass wir immer mal wieder irgendwie,
macht angepampt oder angestupst oder darauf hingewiesen werden wir sollten doch bitte accounts in dezentralen sozialen netzwerken mehr pushen oder betreiben oder sonst was,
ich habe seit einiger zeit ich weiß gar nicht seit wann einen account bei,
chaos dort social das ist ein mastodon das ist im prinzip ein dezentralisierte twitter funktioniert nach meinem dafürhalten ziemlich gut.
Und,
jetzt ist natürlich die die sache ich hab,
nur so so viel zeit in meinem leben soziale netzwerke zu bespielen.
Ich muss ja irgendwann auch nochmal arbeiten und deswegen benutze ich ein cross poster dass der also wenn ich etwas auf mastodon,
veröffentliche dann wird es gleich wird es auch auf twitter veröffentlicht oder wenn ich etwas auf twitter veröffentlicht wird es auch auf mastodon veröffentlicht der cross poster ist ziemlich klug weil er auch antworten und so dann eben herausnimmt also wenn ich eine antwort auf mastodon wird dann nicht auf twitter gekostet postet und so weiter und so fort,
funktioniert eigentlich ziemlich gut und ich bin sehr überzeugt von diesem von diesem,
ansatz dem mastodon und ich stehe dem sehr positiv gegenüber und die community wird da im moment als angenehmer beschrieben was aber sicherlich erstmal noch nur damit zu tun hat ist einfach weniger leute sind.
Ja und wenn es für viele werden dann ist er genau derselbe kram wie überall auch.
Na das sind jetzt nicht wenn jetzt nicht andere menschen sein nur weil die technik anders ist aber das ist auch ein anderes thema masse dann kann man benutzen kann man sich selber aufsetzen hat dann eben seinen dezentrales twitter das heißt ich bin dann,
punkt social
und man kann dann eben etwas was ich auch sowieso mastodon punkt org oder was auch immer sein kennen wir auch machen wir auch mit finden wir auch gut,
aber bitte respektiert er auch unsere begrenzte bandbreite.
Überhaupt solche sozialen netzwerke dazu bespielen zu antworten und daher eben auch die zögerlichkeit sich noch so ein ding ans bein zu binden.
Also du sagst wir ich habe keinen solchen account weil ich einfach.
Für mich beschlossen habe dass ich irgendwie genug kanäle habe die ich derzeit bediene und ich halt immer auf dem punkt stehe dass wir nicht in irgendeinem netzwerk teilnehme dann will ich da auch richtig dran teilnehmen.
Und wenn ich da so kommunikation reingesteckt bekomme und ich nehme dann daran aber nicht teil dann ist irgendwie auch quatsch das ist wie eine e-mail adresse veröffentlichen und die nicht lesen.
Machst du da auch.
Ja also ich weiß ich.
Also ich habe tatsächlich
hier zugeben ich habe ein problem mit diesem mit
der informationsflut die auf mich ein hagelt ich habe seit einigen monaten schwimme ich in in e-mails und versuche damit unterschiedlichen technischen lösungen irgendwie
übersicht reinzubringen vorzufinden altern anhand von adressen und stichwörtern oder themen oder freds zu priorisieren,
das ist wird irgendwann ist es halt nicht mehr so einfach und dann dauert's halt auch mal zwei drei wochen bis sie,
bestimmte auf bestimmte nachrichten antwortet und diese sozialen netzwerke haben
zumindest mein mastodon client hat nicht so gute eigenschaften da zu sortieren,
müssen wir mal gucken und das ist eben alles alles arbeit aber du könntest dir durchaus wenigstens so ein cross poster machen tim weil die leute die dann lieber mastodon machen die wollen ja vielleicht auch deine tweets lesen.
Nee ich will keine cross poster haben explizit das ist technologien dich nichts zu tun haben will.
Jo jo jo.
Nein ich möchte einfach wenn ich in einem netzwerk kommuniziert dann will ich da selbst kommunizieren und wenn nicht dass irgendeiner software überlasse
irgendwelche entscheidungen für mich fällt wann wo wie worauf geantwortet werden soll oder irgendwas weitergeleitet werden soll dann habe ich einfach meine kommunikation nicht mehr unter kontrolle und das ist für mich einfach ein totales
no-go so und ja meinetwegen machst du dann gerne wenn's irgendwie mal einen grund gibt warum
also was ich damit tun kann was ich sozusagen sonst nicht tun kann und was ich und wenn die software halt passt,
und meistens sind so meine erfahrungen mit,
ja mit kleinsten schlecht sind schon bei twitter schlecht,
ich würde twitter sicherlich nicht mehr benutzen wenn es nicht gäbe.
Womit ich auch nur noch irgendwie fünfzig prozent der der features benutzen kann dieses netz eigentlich so bietet aber so ist es dann halt.
Das bringt uns so zum ende der sendung vielleicht noch kleiner kleine kleine suche meldung,
noch die,
band systemabsturz logbuch netzpolitik berichtete nicht nur sondern hatte sie auch singend in der sendung auf dem camp bringt demnächst ein video raus von ihrem song,
verdächtig und auch alles in c null lizenz sucht aber noch händeringend leute die vielleicht bock hätten,
dafür für dieses release ein cooles cover zu machen,
falls ihr mein da weiterhelfen zu können dann schreib dir doch mal an auf twitter system unterstrich absturz.
Ja und die gibt's wohl auch auf dem kongress.
Wir haben die kein master deinen account.
Da geht sie hin die freiheit.
Ne die haben ja auch damals bei uns in der sendung erzählt dass sie sogar einen instagram-account unterhalten.
Sie sind moderne sind jung.
Spalter.
So dann,
müssen wir noch oder möchte ich noch danken dominik war glaube ich der name den ich jetzt die letzten drei sendungen.
Vergessen habe oder nicht nicht zugänglich hatte also vielen herzlichen dank.
Hallo.
Ich weiß auch jetzt dass der name durch einen nächsten namen ersetzt wird den ich jetzt gerade wieder nicht dabei habe um zu danken.
So ist das immer wenn man damit erstmal anfängt dann kommst du den teufelsküche.
Ich freue mich und ich danke wollte nochmal generell allen danken die uns hier oder die mir hier im letzten jahr entweder direkte spenden haben zukommen lassen oder was von meiner wunschliste geschenkt haben.
Das freut mich immer sehr am meisten freue ich mich natürlich über feedback wie das was wir heute am anfang der sendung verkündet haben.
Ich bin mach das hier aus idealismus und der wird eben,
eher durch persönliche unterstützung befeuert und weniger dadurch dass ich hier mir in porsche finanzieren möchte wenn ich.
Den als lebensziel hätte würde ich wahrscheinlich was anderes machen.
Ich persönlich mache das nur zu meiner persönlichen bereicherung und will natürlich kein porsche haben.
Ja in dem sinne auch danke dir alle dieses jahr unterstützt haben es waren viele mehr als noch im letzten jahr und so kann es gerne weitergehen,
denn das bringt mich schon auf
interessante ideen was man denn im nächsten jahr alles noch ein wenig mehr in turbo-gang schalten könnte abgesehen von überhaupt mehr sendung,
dazu vielleicht dann anfang des jahres mehr,
jetzt entlassen wir euch ins neue jahrzehnt und kongress modus je nachdem wo ihr so euer jahresende verbringen möchtet und dann sehen wir uns in den goldenen zwanziger jahren.
Ja bis dahin tschau tschau.
Tschüss.